تركز القوات الامريكيه في سوريا لا بل
تكثف من عملياتها في الاونه الاخيره ضد
تنظيم داعش بشكل لافت غارات وعمليات
ميدانيه لا تخلو من المخاطر طبعا وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه البنتاجون اعلنت انك
كثفت غراضها على تنظيم داعش في سوريا
ونفدت نفذت نتي 10 غاره بالمروحيات
وعمليات بريه لقتل او اعتقال كبار عناصر
التنظيم خلال الشهر الحالي فقط تنفذ الجيش
الامريكي ما لا يقل عن 10 عمليات وغارات
وقال متحدث باسم القياد المركزيه
الامريكيه ان ذلك شملله ثلاث عمليات
الثلاثاء الماضي مع عقوبه سوريا
الديمقراطيه ادت الى اعتقال سته من عناصر
داعش ادت احدى العمليات الى اعتقال ما
وصفه الجيش الامريكي بانه مسؤول كبير في
داعش يدعى الزبيدي ثماني غلط اخرى من
بينها السبع في وقت سابق هذا الشهر وواحده
اخرى في اوله اكتوبر قتلت او القت القبض
على عناصر اخرين من داعش لكن مسؤولي
القياده امتنعوا عن تقديم تفاصيل عن اي من
الغارات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
مسؤولون عسكريون قالوا ان الغارات البريه
والعمليات الاخرى تبقي تنظيم داعش في حاله
التاهب لكنها لا تخلو من المخاطر ففي احدى
الغارات الاخيره كانت القوات الامريكيه
على الارض حوالي 3 ساعات تقريبا واشتبكت
باطلاق نار كثيف مع عناصر التنظيم
القياده المركزيه قال ان كل عمليه يتم
تخطيط لها بعنايه وتاخذ في الاعتبار
المخاطر عبر تكثيف العمليات الاستخباراتيه
تتم المداهمات عاده في الليل باستخدام
المروحيات لقوات العمليات الخاصه شملت ست
عمليات في الثامن من ديسمبر ادت الى
اعتقال خمسه من عناصر التنظيم فيما سنه
غاره اخرى في الحادي عشر من ديسمبر اصبرت
عن مقتل اثنين من مسؤولين داعش فيما
استهدفت غاره اخرى فالسادس من اكتوبر
بالقرب من القامشلي شمال شرق سوريا مسؤولا
في داعش يعتبر مهربا للاسلحه والمقاتلين
يعرفوا باسم راكان وحيد الشمري وتم
التصفياته كانت القياده المركزيه اعلنت في
الثلاثين من نوفمبر عن مقتل ابو الحسن
الهاشمي القريشي الذي تم تحديده على انه
قيادي في التنظيم في ما وصف مسؤولون
امريكيون قتله بانه الضرب اخرى لدعش ولا
طالما اعتبرت مثل هذه الغارات محفوفه
بالمخاطب ما وضع قوات العمليات الخاصه
الامريكيه في مواقف يمكن ان تتعرض فيها
لكمين او لمهاجمين بطريقه اخرى وقد تثير
وفاه احد افراد الخدمه الامريكيه في سوريا
تساؤلات من الكونغرس حول قيمه استهداف
عناصر داعش هناك الذين يتم استبدالهم
بسرعه بافراد اخرين من التنظيم ولا يزال
خطر داعش كبيرا في سوريا التي تضم ثلاثين
مركز احتجاز يؤوي الاهلاف من المقاتل من
المسجونين اضافه الى ان المخيمات القريبه
تضم نحو 56 الف شخص معظمه من النساء
والاطفال المرتبطين بالمقاتلين المسجونين
وبالتالي ربما تكون مخيمات قنبله
تحتفظ الولايات المتحده بحواله 1,000 جندي
في مواقع مختلفه داخل سوريا وقال مسؤولون
الى الهجمات الصاروخيه والهجمات الاخرى هي
تذكير منتظم بالاخطار التي تشكلها الجماعه
لذلك وجبات تكثيف واستهداف وهو ما حصل
فعلا
[موسيقى]